[Music]
on this Tuesday night bc's polarizing
pipeline protests spread across Canada
the BC legislature gets blocked but not
all First Nations are opposed to this
pipeline will tell you why more
Canadians back home and under quarantine
while hundreds more remain confined to
cruise ships counting the days
terrifying bus ride and the teenagers
who will live to tell the tale
plus discovering the Reaper of death the
Tyrannosaurus
terrorized Alberta
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with protests that have popped
up across this country disrupting travel
and trade there a show of solidarity for
a small group of hereditary chiefs in
northern British Columbia who don't want
a natural gas pipeline crossing their
land even though it has the support of
20 elected band councils along the route
[Applause]
in Victoria protestors blocked entrances
to the provincial legislature hours
before the spring session was due to
start and in Toronto they obstructed a
major intersection bringing traffic to a
standstill and protesters are crippling
rail lines - via rail says it's been
forced to cancel 157 passenger trains
because of protests on the tracks
disrupting travel for 24,000 people and
today CN Rail said it's been forced to
shut down parts of its network of
freight trains it is actually also
illegal because it it infringes on the
railway safety act for obvious reasons
it's dangerous - to actually block the
rail rails when that is happening and so
we're very concerned about it from that
point of view the Transport Minister
says it's up to the provinces to get
injunctions to remove the protesters
what started as a blockade on a remote
forest access road in northern BC has
now become a rallying cry for supporters
across the country who were using the
hashtag-- shut down Canada we'll take
you to northern BC in just a moment but
we begin with Erik Sorensen on what the
protesters want more than 3,000
kilometers from the proposed gas
pipeline in northern BC the Tyendinaga
Mohawk have taken a stand in eastern
ontario via rail forced to cancel dozens
of passenger trains through the most
populated rail corridor in the country
CN says the impact is being felt beyond
Canada's borders and is harming the
country's reputation as a stable and
viable supply chain partner the dispute
centers on the proposed coastal gas link
pipeline in northern BC several wet
solet's and bands along the route
supported but hereditary leaders by and
large do not and several protesters who
set up
blockades were arrested sparking
protests across the country here's the
issue the pipeline would deliver natural
gas for export from near Dawson Creek
670 kilometers to the Pacific coast at
Kitimat but the route bisects the wet so
'it and traditional territory the
protests began near Houston BC but after
the Mounties made arrests the protests
began to spread to the Port of Vancouver
in the BC Legislature and cities across
the country some one-day protests others
involve ongoing blockades of rail lines
CN lines in northern BC and in Eastern
Ontario and a CP rail line near Montreal
a small blockade is all it takes on the
counter walk a reserve outside Montreal
the snow-covered tracks tell the story
the trains aren't running protests in
response began last week in BC including
one outside the Port of Vancouver today
at the container terminal in Halifax a
demonstration by Mick mah first nations
showing coast-to-coast solidarity enough
is enough we want Canada to wake up this
is not what reconciliation is it's not
what reconciliation should look like one
protest brought the dispute right into
the Toronto offices of the Federal
Minister of crown indigenous relations
Carolyn Bennett the minister would not
comment publicly but clearly doesn't
want to be drawn into this dispute
issuing a statement that the coastal Gas
Link project falls under provincial
jurisdiction and that no order of
government can direct the RCMP but
others say it's not just about a
pipeline it's about indigenous rights
that Ottawa and the provinces cannot
sidestep this is about native
sovereignty native law and the right to
make decisions - what happens to them
their nations and their lands
indigenous and other protesters are
relatively small in number but they're
showing the potential for disruption
exists all over the country
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto the
natural gas pipeline at the heart of
this has the support of 20 elected band
councils along the route all of them
have signed benefit agreements with
coastal gas link they believe it will
help communities become less reliant on
federal funding it's a few its own
hereditary chiefs and their supporters
who are blocking construction of it and
who the RCMP have been arresting global
Sarah MacDonald is near the site in
northern BC tonight Sarah Donna court
appearances today for those arrested
here in northern BC on Monday where that
lucrative pipeline project is deeply
divisive 7 arrests said the
longest-standing holdout in what's so at
a nation outside of Houston BC on Monday
marked the end of the enforcement of the
injunction 28 people opposed to that
natural gas pipeline have now been
arrested for refusing to leave the
unceded territory that pipeline is
slated to run through but many members
of that same First Nation want the
pipeline built it's an initiative
promising jobs and funding to indigenous
communities in exchange for access to
their resources it may be lucrative but
still it's also polarizing drawing a
deep wedge between those for and against
it the benefits of our people working
out there that they have gainful
employment and if they cannot provide
for their families I've not heard
anybody who said I love this pipeline am
so happy it's going ahead what people
have said is I want the job I want a
good-paying job the livelihoods of many
British Columbians in this region depend
on that injunction remaining impactful
and the road to their worksite remaining
clear of obstructions the question is
how long it will stay that way with work
expected to resume this week Donna all
right Sarah McDonald and Smithers BC
thanks progress is being made getting
stranded Canadians out of the corona
virus outbreak zone
a second government chartered plane
touched down this morning at CFB Trenton
after flying overnight from China and
making a refueling stop in Vancouver the
188 passengers on board have now joined
more than 200 others in a two-week
quarantine in China the outbreak has
reached a grim milestone according to
Chinese media more than 1,100 people
have now died and the virus is still
spreading there are now more than 44,000
confirmed cases most of them in China at
the heart of the outbreak in the city of
Wuhan millions of people are still under
quarantine information on what's
happening on the ground there is limited
state-run media is posting video like
this patience dancing at a makeshift
hospital trying to show that people are
staying positive the situation in the
region though remains bleak public
frustration is building over how the
outbreak has been handled today it was
reported several senior Chinese
officials have been punished they were
removed from their positions for
dereliction of duty the World Health
Organization has finally come up with an
official name for this strain of the
virus it's now called Kovan 19 the head
of the whu-oh says the name purposefully
does not refer to any people place or
animals that's to avoid any stigma
he describes the virus as public enemy
number one and calls on the world to
tackle the threat a virus can have more
powerful consequences than any terrorist
action we have to use the current window
of opportunity to hit hard and stand in
unison to fight this virus in every
corner public health officials in Canada
say the risk to Canadians is low but as
Michael Couture reports they're taking
no chances with those people returning
from the epicenter of the outbreak the
second and likely last Canadian
government evacuation flight from Wuhan
China touched down at CFB Trenton in
Ontario early Tuesday morning 130
Canadians and 58 accompanying family
members were on board hundreds of
Canadians registered with global affairs
remain in who by province it's unclear
if those people want to
but it's unlikely that the government
will go get them each situation is
different and we're assessing what kinds
of supports are needed and whether or
not more people want to come back from
Hawaii the ones who just returned will
go through the same 14-day quarantine as
the others who arrived home last week
but this latest group will be in a less
modern facility as a result those housed
at Hastings Hall will have to share
bathrooms according to Canada's chief
Public Health Officer elsewhere on the
base we're getting a sense of daily life
through the lens of Joanna Wu which
includes people walking around in hazmat
suits the Vancouver native has been
posting videos on YouTube documenting
each day from when she left Wuhan to the
meals she's eating in Trenton I actually
went out yesterday to try to test the
two meter rule because we're supposed to
stay away from people like at least two
meter but then I walked around yesterday
it seems like that was in a very strict
like you could stand next to someone the
quarantine passengers on the diamond
Princess cruise ship are settling into a
routine BC man Nigel Cole says he and
his husband are allowed brief walks on
the promenade deck as they try to pass
the time we're counting the days it's
not marking marks on the wall yet but as
they do in the movies we might couple
that it goes beyond the 19th that's when
the quarantine should end and that's
when Cole and thousands of others on
board hope they'll finally be able to
head home
Michael accretor global news Ottawa and
Japanese public health officials now say
39 more people on board the diamond
princess have tested positive for the
virus that brings the total on board
that ship to 174 and there's trouble now
for another cruise ship stranded at sea
because of the corona virus the Wester
dam owned by Holland America has been
turned away from yet another port the
cruise ship left from Hong Kong on
February 1st with more than 2,200 people
on board including 271 Canadians it was
supposed to be a 14 day trip with stops
in Japan and Taiwan but Japan refused to
let the ship dock because of the
coronavirus Taiwan the Philippines and
the u.s. territory of Guam
also barred its entry it appeared
yesterday the nightmare might end when
the company announced it was headed for
Bangkok Thailand
but now Thai officials say they won't
let passengers off the ship either the
company says it's trying to sort out the
problem and it's spanking passengers for
their patients there's a big shake-up to
health care in Atlantic Canada New
Brunswick's government says it has no
choice but to cut back emergency
departments in some rural communities
critics fear people could die as a
result
as Ross Lord reports managing a
struggling health care system isn't a
problem unique to that part of Canada
with the New Brunswick health care
system itself falling ill the province
has decided it's time for a radical
remedy we believe these changes will
help address the lack of staff resources
our system is experiencing the toughest
medicine closing emergency departments
overnight in six hospitals but those
hospitals are being promised additional
mental health services and 120 acute
care beds are being converted to
long-term chronic care beds mostly for
seniors awaiting nursing homes the
government says the emergency
departments are only seeing a handful of
patients overnight many of them not
actual emergencies underutilize capacity
when you can see at times two patients
at night when you can see 22 in the day
I think that's a good thing
not so according to people in Sackville
near New Brunswick's border with Nova
Scotia our biggest concern is deaths a
petition opposing the overnight closures
at the Sackville Hospital is growing
with signatures rapidly outnumbering the
town's population we feel blindsided our
government officials feel blindsided our
representatives and the public is just
floored finding better ways to deliver
healthcare is urgent here in Atlantic
Canada which has the oldest population
in the country but researchers say other
parts of Canada should be paying
attention the structure of healthcare is
such that is going to affect all
provinces and in fact most provinces
have to deal with these kinds of issues
health authorities say they've been
asking for these changes for many
years with more than one-third of the
provinces doctors and nurses eligible to
retire within five years they say
changing the structure of healthcare
makes perfect sense
Ross Lord Global News Halifax
there's more turmoil for the royal
family and it involves a Canadian autumn
Philips is divorcing the eldest grandson
of Queen Elizabeth Peter Phillips after
12 years of marriage in a statement the
couple says the separation is sad but
amicable they plan to share custody of
their two daughters the couple met in
her hometown of Montreal while attending
the Grand Prix in 2003 five years later
she became the first Canadian to marry
into the royal family a frightening
moment of impact caught on camera
coming up the ride to school these
students will never forget
this distressing video shows the moment
a school bus crashed and flipped on its
side sending students flying it happened
in December and despite how bad it looks
no one was critically injured eight of
the 25 students though and the 74 year
old driver did go to the hospital the
collision happened when another vehicle
failed to stop at a red light police say
the driver of that vehicle was driving
with a suspended license it is a big
night in New Hampshire the polls are now
closed and voters in one of America's
smallest states are hoping to make a big
impact in the Democratic presidential
race Bernie Sanders is leading right now
and Joe Biden is running way behind the
field of candidates got a bit smaller
tonight Andrew yang announced he has
dropped out of the race as Jackson
prosecco reports from New Hampshire
momentum for the remaining Democratic
candidates now is crucial the only thing
certain about the first-in-the-nation
primary is the uncertainty felt by
voters at the ballot box this year has
been so difficult to decide why is that
because they were all over the place I
think a lot of the Democratic candidates
are great and I probably could have
voted for five of them but it really
just came down to who who I really
agreed with many Democrats remained
undecided up until the last moment
overwhelmed by a crowded field of
candidates and the desire to defeat
Donald Trump I'm praying that he doesn't
get in in November so who's the person
to beat him it's got to be Biden or
Sanders somebody within the party
but joe biden's campaign appears to be
faltering early down in the polls and
reportedly low on cash we're still
mildly hopeful here in New Hampshire and
we'll see what happens all right bye
left New Hampshire before the results
were known to rally with supporters in
South Carolina where he hopes to turn
things around
Pete Buda jabs the young former mayor of
South Bend Indiana has grabbed many of
Biden's voters can you pull off the big
success and it feels like it's taping up
well positioning himself as a moderate
and electable alongside senator Amy
Klobuchar who too has seen her number
surged she won two of New Hampshire's
small precincts overnight but it's the
progressive wing of the party led by
Bernie Sanders that could be on the path
to a statewide victory buoyed by a
strong showing in Iowa and legions of
grassroots supporters nationwide the guy
is stuck to his roots from beginning to
end
Jackson all the polls closed now what
are the early results well Donna with
about a quarter of the results in Bernie
Sanders is in the lead no surprise he's
from the neighborhood
p-goon a judge in second but the
breakout star of the night seems to be
Amy Klobuchar she was fifth after Iowa
right now she's in a very strong third
place position a massive increase in
numbers for her and so Donna leaving the
state she may be one to watch while
candidates like Joe Biden try to salvage
their campaigns
all right wants to still watch for
Jackson and New Hampshire things still
ahead the snowfall of a decade that is
melting hearts it's not often you can
have a snowball fight in Baghdad this is
just the second time in a century Iraq's
capital has seen snow the last time was
2008 this wintery wonder is mostly
melted now but the snow brought a
welcome moment of delight a former
dictator may finally face justice
Sudan's Omar al-bashir may finally
appear before the International Criminal
Court where he's charged with war crimes
crimes against humanity and genocide
Bashir was ousted from power last April
after nearly three decades of ruling the
country with an iron fist in a dramatic
shift Sudan's new government has
promised to send anyone facing an ICC
warrant to the hague to face trial the
court issued warrants for Basheer's
arrest in 2009 and 2010 he's accused of
masterminding a scorched earth campaign
in the Darfur region that killed 300,000
people and forced nearly 3 million
people from their homes
I'm Heather Eurex West in Drumheller
Alberta where paleontologists have
discovered a new species of Tyrannosaur
13 million years older than t-rex that
story ahead on global national
and there you have it a Canadian record
for the Toronto Raptors they beat the
Minnesota Timberwolves in Toronto last
night giving them the longest winning
streak in a single season by a major
professional team based in Canada the
Calgary Stampeders held the record until
now after 14 straight wins back in 2016
well it's not a raptor but it is
Canadian and it's making headlines
around the world a new dinosaur species
has been discovered in Alberta it's
thought to be the oldest member of the
t-rex family and just its name is enough
to make you shudder Heather York's West
explains how the Reaper of death was
found there's a reason why this Monster
is known as the king the fierce t-rex
has inspired movies and captured our
imagination for more than 100 years but
UFC researchers have now discovered
another Tyrannosaur roamed the earth
millions of years before the mighty
t-rex hunted its prey Senado thristy
comes from a time period that's roughly
seventy nine point five million years
old so that's a rock layer which is the
oldest point in Canada where we start
getting dinosaur fossils the fossilized
skull fragments were first discovered in
southern Alberta 10 years ago but it
wasn't until PhD student Jared Morris
began studying the bones that he
realized how special they were I came by
looking at it and noticed that's when I
started noticing the features that kind
of made it distinct a new species of
Tyrannosaur much older than canadian
scientists had ever seen before
I think that's really important with
this particular specimen is that it is
the oldest Tyrannosaur known from sort
of northerly North America which is
really exciting because it tells us
about a period of time that we know very
little about dinosaur ecosystems
paleontologists only know of two other
dinosaurs from this period of time a
duckbill and a horned dinosaur but as a
vicious carnivore Thanatos would have
been at the top of the food chain the
animal would have been a typical
Tyrannosaurus this means it's a
two-legged animal with very short four
limbs only two fingers on its hand and
the big massive skulls with big fat
teeth Thanatos was smaller than t-rex
illustrating to scientists
that as the species evolved tyrannosaurs
grew Thanatos also looked a little
different it had a series of ornamental
bumps on its snout of course researchers
are still trying to figure out why it
lived here who else was around
Morris hopes to find those answers as he
continues his career right now though
he's focused on finishing that PhD
Heather Eurex West Global News
Drumheller Alberta and that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm Donna
Friesen tonight's your Canada is this
coyote hanging out in Calgary we'd love
to see your Canada please email it to
viewers at global national comm and
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]